firemen have not yet prepared wiltjer
for this so he doesn't know where he's
going he just going
he ran in front of the fire truck oh my
god they were panicking and that only
makes Wilshire more powerful and less
understanding about why we don't want
them to run through that door thank you
that's our biggest e this is our biggest
fear
no that's why we shut we shut the
you
that's a big blind spot I mean we can't
see cars at park in front of us I mean
this poor guy back here driving in the
rear
dogs don't see the danger what they see
is a reaction to the situation
and we react in panic nervous fearful
and all these things they go to us to
save their life
we actually setting them up to get hurt
so the exercise at the garage door is a
very important exercise because it's
life in that situation here
you know I practice energy by the
language to let him know that that's my
area wilshire needed to understand that
every area here is belong to you
there you go this is how they respect
because the area's bolon to pack leader
and in tow he's invited to go over there
he's now welcome there we go that's what
we
it was amazing where he stopped right at
the door
he was able to control him in minimal
amount of time whereas we would have
been chasing them down Wilshire down
Wilshire which we have yeah a few double
caddy he almost knows there's an
invisible line there didn't it yeah very
good
that's right may you back that's right
and you don't have to give a fection all
the time
that's right very good that's right okay
so you right there go for it protest
these protesting
protests why because we're taking his
Flay's away it's like a kid right a
little time pretender right there yeah
it's on the board he was a dancer
especially because he came with a
different energy to accomplish the
behavior
puppies normally don't resist leadership
puppies always receive leadership from
the day they're born we are the species
they don't practice leadership over our
dogs and a daily basis and this is what
our dogs become frustrated and dominance
hyper what we have here is a frustrated
puppy
that's right our that's right
you